PAUL COVELL: Hi, good morning.
My name is Paul and
I'm a product manager
on Brillo and Weave.
And I am also looking after
security for the products.
It looks like you can see that.
So I'm going to jump right in.
There's a lot to cover.
And I may have time for some
questions at the very end.
But I'll also be at the office
hours for the next two hours.
So feel free to come
by and talk to me there
if you do have questions.
So I'd like to start with
just, what is IoT security?
IoT can be a pretty broad term.
I'd like to give a little
context for the next half hour
so we can all be thinking
about it in the same way.
It's about all the
things in the product.
And this is especially
important when it comes to IoT.
There's usually several
different parts-- a cloud
server, an app, a
mobile app or two,
and then the device itself.
So if we want to talk
seriously about security,
we have to think about
each of these things
and the different ways
they might be attacked.
And we also have to think
about all the networks
that they use to communicate.
The second thing that
we feel is important is
that this isn't just
another web service, right.
These devices are in your
home, your office, car,
they can record data,
they can control things.
And if one of them
is compromised
it can be used as
a jumping off point
to attack other
things in that area.
Let's take a quick example.
Here my webcam is
monitoring my living room.
This picture of my dog
ends up everywhere.
So now the data could be stolen
from any of these places,
right.
It's not just on my camera.
And it isn't really
just about the data.
If they managed to
steal the credentials,
then they might be able to
control my webcam remotely
in the future and I might not
even that they're doing it.
So we really have to
look at the whole system
if we want to build
secure products.
So this sort of
thinking led us to a few
of the big elements of
security in Brillo and Weave.
And you may have seen these
from the first day keynote,
but just to reiterate,
the first item
is that the owner needs to
be able to grant and revoke
specific privileges to people,
apps, and other devices.
And this also means
that the system itself
needs a way to authenticate the
owner and those other people,
apps, and device.
And so we'll talk
about how that works.
The second thing is
that any user data
needs to be stored securely
on the device, on the servers.
It needs to be transmitted
securely among these things.
There's no cheating
on local networks
that you think are secure or
backend cloud servers that just
don't encrypt the stored data.
And the final thing is--
oh, I had a click there.
Sorry.
And the final thing
is that the devices
need to be resistant
to attacks, updatable,
and recoverable in the case
that there's a problem.
So with that in mind,
let's look at a few places
where real world products
have had problems in the past.
I'll leave out the names
but if you're interested
there's a long reading
list at the end
and you can go
educate yourself more.
So, a home automation system
that trusts the local network.
This particular home automation
product has an iPhone app.
The iPhone app can be used to
control your home remotely.
So how does it do this?
It gives the iPhone app
an authorization token
that it presents to the cloud
server when you are remote,
and the cloud server then
presents that to your house
and you can control it.
But it turns out,
they'll actually
give any iPhone app on your
local network this token.
But it's OK, right?
You only let your friends
on your home network
and you trust your friends.
But the catch that we all
have to be thinking about here
is that that means you also
have to trust any device they
add to the network.
And that that device
isn't running any malware
or hasn't been compromised.
So now you're
several layers down.
So if any of those
devices are compromised
or are running a
malicious application,
that device can then request
this token, get this token,
send it off somewhere
that can be then be used
to control your home remotely.
So it's much better if you
just don't trust other devices
in the local network, and
you use sort of an end
to end authentication and
encryption model with all
of your communication.
I'd like to complete the story
a little bit because this
was something that
frankly was news to me
when I started really
digging into this area,
into the world of how a malware
gets onto a laptop or a phone.
We're all familiar
with the basic advice,
don't click on links
that you get from someone
you don't know, et cetera.
We all do that.
Right?
But it turns out with the
right kind of exploit,
a malicious or
compromised website
can actually install
malware on your machine
just by you loading
the web page.
So for example,
a zero to exploit
in your browser,
your Flash player,
your Java Runtime can
actually load up on the page
and plop some code on
and you might never
know that's happening.
There is also a whole market
where people buy and sell
these exploits.
So this does happen.
It can be a fairly expansive
exploit to implement.
So not all products might
consider this attack case.
But mitigating it
is fairly cheap
and it's the same
we just mentioned.
If you do end to end
authentication encryption
devices, you don't trust
your local network,
you can mitigate the impact
of this kind of attack also.
So we should take a
serious look at that.
OK.
Let's move on to
look at smart TVs
with weak secure boot schemes.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with secure boot,
it's simply a way to make sure
that the image that the device
runs after it boots is authentic
and hasn't been tampered with.
So that if someone does insert
malware into the device when
you reboot it should detect
that and say, something's wrong,
please recover me.
It's also a very
important part of securing
the auto-update process.
So if I'm shipping an
image in from the internet,
I don't want that device to
run the image unless it's
authenticated to be from
the original manufacturer
and also untampered with.
So probably your devices will
implement something like this.
This is something
we'll come back
to but in the case of this
smart TV, they did this.
They implemented a
secure boot model,
but they used a simple
encryption mechanism
and as the secret key they used
the model number of the device.
So you can bet the
hacker community figured
that out pretty
quick and they made
it easy to produce
images for the TV that
contained whatever you want.
So if you're a
weekend hacker and you
want to install some
software on your TV
and have it do some
stuff that you like then
this is actually
really great for you.
But if someone
wants to take over
your TV without you
knowing, then this
is a pretty bad thing.
So one mitigating factor
here is the updates
were only possible via USB.
That has other
maintenance issues
that we'll talk about later on.
But in this case it meant you
couldn't compromise the devices
remotely by knowing this.
But what it did do is
enable a drive-by attack.
So somebody could walk by
your TV, plug in a USB stick,
get it to load the update,
and then pull the USB stick
and walk along.
So for something
in your home that
might not be a major concern.
Again, you trust your friends,
you trust your house guests,
but a lot of these
televisions are actually
deployed in commercial
retail spaces
where that kind of-- a few
minutes of unmonitored access
might be completely plausible.
So the moral of this story is,
you really should implement
a strong secure boot scheme.
We'll talk more about
what that looks like.
Third example-- this is
kind of a broad example.
A lot of the research that is
being done on IoT devices--
security audits, is showing that
a lot of the servers, the web
servers that people use to
interact with the devices
remotely are very weak
on basic security things
that we've known for a long time
in the web server development
process.
And we touched on
this a little earlier.
This isn't just
another web service.
So you need to take things
a little more seriously.
For example, a lot of websites
don't offer even basic attack
mitigation.
So I can try the
password 100 times
and it doesn't lock me out
and it doesn't insert a delay.
So brute force attacks
become possible.
There's no two
factor authentication
for most websites.
Understandably it takes a
little more work to implement.
But what that
means is you can be
much more vulnerable to
things like phishing attempts.
You put in your password and
then they get your password
and off they go.
And finally they
make it very easy
to simply reset your
password with an email.
So that by itself seems OK
because your email account
might be secure.
But that means then any
of the other mechanisms--
if you're using an
email account that
doesn't have a good password
or doesn't have a two factor
authentication, then
you're vulnerable that way.
So again, when
this account access
might allow you to unlock
your door or your car
or view the webcam
in your house,
you really have to implement
best practices when
it comes to securing
your web server as well.
The final thing I'd like to look
at is a little bit different
and that's because
physical security
isn't always considered
for consumer devices.
And that's fair
in a lot of cases.
If you imagine an attacker who
has persistent physical access
to your device and they can
open it and play around with it,
and if they have
sufficient time and budget,
they'll almost certainly
compromise the device.
There's really-- you could
try to build an ATM machine
but it's seldom worth the cost.
So that doesn't mean it's
not worth considering at all.
And within your
specific use case,
it's worth identifying, what
are the physical attacks
and how they might be
mitigated in your case.
So let's look at this one.
This is a hotel door lock.
It had a configuration port that
was accessible from the outside
with just a couple
of minutes of work.
The attacker did
have to be prepared.
But it was a $40 preparation
and a 30-minute process.
And so then they show up at
the hotel door, plug it in.
They plug it in-- there's
no authorization required
once you're plugged
into the report.
You can just read all the
memory off the device.
So that by itself
maybe allows you
to compromise a single lock.
But on the device,
the manufacturer
had stored a shared
secret key that
was used to authorize many
rooms within the same block.
So it could be the whole hotel.
It could have been
if they separated it
by wing or something.
So by having this
key, then the attacker
could create a card that would
work in any of these doors that
shared the same block.
So we're talking about
just a few minutes
of physical access and boom.
What are some lessons
we can learn from this?
Well, you might say take
away the program import,
and that might be
practical in some cases.
But this is always a usability
straight off with security.
So it might be more
appropriate to leave the device
with the programming
port, but implement
some kind of
authorization on it if you
recognize the people
might access it
without authorization.
But beyond that, the
most important thing
is, think about
what happens when
your device is compromised.
How widespread is the
value of that compromise?
So in this case they really
should have come up with a way
to scope that shared key
down a little bit-- come up
with another way so that if
one device is compromised,
you don't get access
to lots of rooms.
You just get access
to that room.
So up to now we've
talked about what
elements should go
into security and we've
looked at some empirical
lessons from other devices.
There's a lot more of
those, but I didn't
want to take forever on that.
So let's look at how Brillo
and Weave can help you make
your IT products more secure.
Weave handles the user
accounts and sharing for you.
So it provides an
integrated solution
across all of the devices.
It understands the
concept of a user.
And that user is the same user
when you log in on the web
and it's the same user when
you log in on the phone.
It's the same user that
the device thinks it is.
And that's all based
on Google accounts.
So right off the bat
you get this sort
of state of the art
user authentication
that's built in there-- password
strength indicators, repeated
bad login attempt blocking,
optional two factor
authentication with several
different mechanisms.
On top of that, we've added
some IoT specific features.
So a secure way to
identify a specific user
on all platforms,
which I mentioned.
But from there the owner
can share that access
and revoke that access
from other users who
are understood in the same way.
So that provides a very
consistent experience
for users across many devices.
And think about it
like Google doc sharing
but for your devices.
So you pick the device,
you share the device.
You pick the privilege,
share the privilege.
So the next thing Weave provides
is data transmission security.
Like we talked about, all
of this endpoint security
is fairly useless if I
can sniff your traffic
or spoof your traffic whenever
it goes over the network.
So Weave secures everything
end to end using TLS,
whether it's the local
network or over the internet.
For those of you who are
interested in the Bluetooth
BLE, we'll be doing work
there as well so stay tuned.
And then all the data
stored in the Weave cloud
is encrypted when it's on disk.
So that limits the exposure
in all these different areas
without any manual
effort on your part.
So all of that's good
and it makes sense,
but the big wins start to
come when you can use Weave
instead of implementing
these things yourself.
So the more you can use the
Weave and Google provided
services, the more you reuse the
existing code that we already
have and the best practices
that are implemented.
And for the parts
that are maintained
by us, that's simply less
work you need to do yourself.
For each of these items,
it's the kind of thing
where you could choose.
You don't have to
take all of them.
You can take some of them.
You can add your own
service next to it.
We're trying to strike
a balance with Weave
so that it provides
a lot of value,
but when you have
a particular need
to go outside of that you can.
So that way you can
capture as much of this
as is relevant for your product.
So let's look at Brillo.
Brillo provides
integrated updates.
We've spent a lot
of time on this
in some of the other talks,
particularly the services
talk yesterday.
And so for those of you
who are interested in that,
I'd recommend you go and review
that if you didn't see it.
In a nutshell though,
devices that are secure today
will have some exploit tomorrow.
We can't anticipate
what that will
be so we need to provide
a full service solution.
Google maintains
the operating system
and we make security
fixes available.
Developers fix-- I've sort of
got a little progress bar here.
Developers fix their software,
or with the new distribution
of our software they pop
up to the developer portal.
The devices in the
field pull it down.
We secure the payloads.
You sign the image so the
device will verify that image
before it will run it.
And then as a second step
here, crash reporting
isn't always thought of
as a security element
but stability and security
really go hand in hand.
Things that can
crash your device
can potentially also be
used to exploit your device.
So watching crashes and
trying to understand
where your big
stability problems are,
we feel is also an
important part of security.
I bundle it with
updates because it's
one way to tell if your
updates are sticking.
Finally, updates are
applied in the background
so they don't interrupt
device behavior.
This is fairly important
because you really
don't want to end
up at the situation
where the fix for an exploit
has been available for months
but nobody's installed
it so all of your routers
are vulnerable to
attack for example.
So finding a way to
allow the consumer
to get updates that they
will actually apply,
and that doesn't either have a
lot of friction to that process
or cause them a lot of
worry is really, really
important to getting people to
actually apply these updates.
Finally-- and it looks like we
will have time for questions.
Finally, I'd like to end
with a discussion on defense
in depth, which is a
kind of security ideology
that we feel works
quite well in this area.
So this is a photo of the
Dun Aengus Castle on the Aran
Islands in Ireland.
And I've only been there once,
and it was a long time ago,
but it really stuck with me.
And you could see somewhat
from this picture--
I looked for my own pictures
but I didn't have any.
It was too long ago.
So these rocks in front-- when
you approach from the top,
it's like, what is
this field of rocks?
And actually it's
cavalry defense.
So if you got to the
islands, and you got up
the 200-foot cliff to the
castle, with your horses--
Yeah.
You'd be so tired.
But then you have to
cross this boulder field
with sort of spiky
rocks pointing
toward you that the horses
wouldn't be able to navigate.
You have to climb the wall.
Once you're inside
there's additional rooms.
So for you Game of
Thrones fans out there,
this is more difficult to
attack than King's Landing.
But the summary here is that
if one defense fails then
there's others waiting to make
it harder to actually capture
any benefit from your successful
attack on the first defense.
So an attacker has to be very
persistent and very successful
through many layers before they
can really get to their goal.
We think about device
security in much the same way.
So verified boot, which is what
we call the secure boot that we
talked about-- verified boot
starts from the very moment
the processor powers on.
It verifies all of the
software that you're
going to run, all the way
down to the root file system
where the executables live.
So any changes or compromises
there will be caught.
If something makes it
past that then there's
process sandboxing
and IPC, interprocess
control authentication, so
that if a single process is
compromised it can't escape and
gain additional privileges very
easily or it can't attack
other processes very easily.
We have mandatory access
control mechanisms.
This was brought up
SELinux and setcomp.
I think Gaurav mentioned
it in the Fireside Chat.
The idea there is just to
provide additional defaults
for anything that you
might have missed.
And then there's all sorts of
other things like tool chain
configuration for
address randomization
so that some of the attacks
that have emerged over the years
and are well known are
protected against without you
having to set any
configuration yourself.
We build all of the
Brillo core services
and set up the operating
system using all these things.
But just as importantly,
we make the tools
configured and available so that
you can build your own software
while continuing to take
advantage of these things.
So that way-- the whole thing.
In addition, we'll keep
adding to this list as we go.
There's lots of little bits that
fit into making an operating
system as secure as
possible and as new
best practices are
found and implemented,
or as things evolve, Brillo
will be tracking that.
So I'd to summarize
what we covered.
Really, IoT security needs
to cover the whole system.
We saw a couple
of examples where
a mistake in one area like
trusting a local network
can allow remote access to
the devices in the home.
It's happening over
and over-- developers
are rolling their own
and rediscovering all
of these problems the hard way.
If you read some of the
security researchers
that have been in the community
for 20 years, they're saying,
hey, these are all problems
we discovered long ago
with web servers and
with other devices
and it's really a shame that
people are rediscovering them.
What we should be
doing is trying
to move some of that knowledge
into this new program.
And finally, Weave and Brillo
provide the building blocks
to build more securely
with less effort.
The one thing I'll end on here,
especially on that last note,
is that security
is both holistic
and quite specific
to the product
that you're trying to build.
So we want to provide best
practices and some checklists
and some tools and
software to make sure
that you can build a secure
system and a secure device.
But we can't do it all
for you, essentially.
The specific attacks
that your device might
want to mitigate against,
the environments it's
going to be in, the special
features that you're
adding or being
asked to add, all
need to be looked at carefully.
One of the ways
in which security
is most commonly broken is
when you designed a system
to fit into a
particular environment
and to do a particular
thing and then
you're asked to apply it in a
slightly different environment
or asked to add a slightly
different feature.
And you either bolt it on
at the end or the marketing
departments sells
it into that area
and then suddenly, like with
smart TVs that they assumed
were secure for a
home, may not be
secure in a retail environment.
So we're really trying to
think about all those places
your device might go and
at least have a plan.
So with that I'll take a
few minutes of questions.
There are mics on the left and
the right, on the first level
here and then I think there's
one up in the balcony.
As other speakers
have pointed out,
I can't see up there very well.
So feel free to holler
if you're up there.
Oh, reading list.
I assume you guys can all
see this offline somewhere
but there's a lot
of good stuff here.
And that's it.
Oh, you want me to go back one?
Yeah.
Do you have a question over
there or just someone standing?
I see.
OK.
I'm not seeing any questions.
Going once, going twice.
OK.
Thanks everyone for coming.
[INAUDIBLE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]